in the process of actually writing
fiction the things that you really want
to write about sort of come to the
surface and they can almost be
embarrassing
because
what story structure do you use
personally well I wanted to say from the
outset that
I I call certain kinds of structures
external structures and others internal
and I'll explain what I mean by that
an external structure is something that
you start with before writing and it's
going to help guide the storytelling for
example
on by page 10
X Y and Z has to have been accomplished
in the plot or by the end of chapter one
a character has to be developed in a
certain way and has to arrive at a
certain level of development
those are what I would call external
structures so the writing is gonna in a
way have to conform to the constraints
of the external structure
the way I think about structure and the
way I
right
teach
and just think about
is
that structure has certain elements and
you can study them but the first thing
to do is write a draft back to Flannery
O'Connor this this was her her idea that
you know the best way to learn how to
write a story is to write a story we've
all you know heard them and read them
and thought about them so try to write
one to the best of your ability and then
go back and look
what have I done here like what's what's
going on and if you can have a teacher
that's great if you can have other
readers that great but you can even do
it yourself
um and so you can ask certain questions
about structure that can help you
improve your use of structure for
example time time is an element of
structure how is time handled in the
Lori Moore story that I was referring to
that I read an example from earlier
um I believe the story takes place on
five consecutive days and then it sort
of goes into the foreseeable future so
the first day
one thing happens the second day another
thing happens Third Day fourth day fifth
day
and then into the future
um you can have a story that takes place
all in one day you can have a story that
takes place over a 40-year period
um the important thing is is it clear
when events are taking place and does
the way time is the way time you
is the way time is used ordered and
presented in a way that best serves the
story and I think these are the kinds of
questions that a writer can ask of
himself after having written something
I'll give you a couple more examples
um point of view point of view is
another element of fiction structure who
is telling us this right like in the
beginning God created the heavens and
the Earth well that's probably not a
first person story because no first
person was back there when God was
creating the universe so that's an
omniscient storytelling voice of some
kind
but when Mona Simpson says in lawns I
steal
that's a very different kind of voice
that's like a first person Voice who is
in some way confessing or at least you
know passing along information about
something that she's doing so is the
point of view established quickly and uh
maintained consistently over the course
of the writing with many Stu with many
Apprentice fiction writers fiction
writers who are just starting to write
and trying to write stories for the
first time they often don't keep the
point of view straight it's sort of
we're in different characters Minds at
different times sometimes we're getting
omniscient information
it's it gets confusing so
point of view is one
um do I have time for oh please okay so
another one is scene scene length and
scene numbers so a question that a
writer can ask himself is were the
scenes long enough and developed enough
and necessary a lot of times uh in an
early draft of an apprentice writer's
work or even an experienced writer there
will either be too many scenes or not
enough scenes and sometimes you can only
tell that after you write a draft and
you see oh I didn't ever cover this like
of course that needs to be in the story
or you know when when you're talking
about structure you're often talking
about
what what
needs to go into the story and What
needs to stay out what is the story
about and what is it not about like
these are the kinds of choices that
fiction writers have to make and some of
them you'll make as your writing a draft
but many of them you'll make after you
have a draft in front of you and you're
thinking about okay
how can I make this as as as good as
possible
um
a huge one for fiction is balance
between background and foregrounded
story the foregrounded story is what's
going on now like I'm talking to you
about fictional structure like that's
what's going on now that's the now of
the story that we're currently living
but before this lots of other things
happen that in some way related to the
moment that we're having now so I would
call those either background or
backstory sometimes they even involve
flashbacks so what is the relationship
in the in the short story
does or a novel between what has
happened and what is happening now there
are many writers like in that Lori Moore
story FaceTime there's almost no back
story all of the back story is implied
by things that the characters say and do
I mean there might be a minimal amount
but not very much and Hemingway often is
the same way The Killers I don't believe
there's any backstory
um it's all told through dialogue and
dramatic action
um so I think there certainly needs to
be some kind of emphasis on foregrounded
story and this is something that
Apprentice writers also need to work on
and be aware of
um you know are they showing enough or
are they relying too much on
explanation summary background because
these things are much easier to write
actually to dramatize the scene takes a
lot more work and so
you'll you'll see Apprentice writers not
doing it but ultimately there has to be
a really good balance between background
and foreground and usually the emphasis
is on
um foreground
um one more that could be mentioned is
plot plot is a huge subject but
essentially it can be boiled down to
what happened how did it happen and why
did it happen and somehow the elements
of the plot have to be arranged and
executed
effectively so something happens it
ramifies it has consequences and you
know you go from some opening action or
line of dialogue or what what have you
and then
you you start to ask questions about
yeah what happened how did it happen and
why did it happen brings us back to
motivation
um and some motivation is explicitly
given by writers and some is not
um
iago's motivations in Othello are not
always clearly
um provided by the writer which was
obviously a choice
um you know Othello may have slept with
iago's wife certainly Iago was passed
over for a promotion and feel slighted
and he feels jealous of Cassio who half
daily Beauty in his life that makes Iago
ugly so Shakespeare gives us
a lot to work with but ultimately why
does someone behave that badly that
destructively
you know some some motivations are
better left unspecified by the writer
and I'm hoping we can go back to
background and foreground for a moment
sure and you spoke of in a prior segment
a story that you've written that's about
a father and son and that this father is
very proud of one aspect of the sun
right but maybe not so much the other
and maybe it has more to do with the
father and what he wanted for his son
and it wasn't maybe the same you know
beer drinking football watching I don't
know I'm just assuming so with the
background and foreground how would you
put this in the story well you could I
like to do both at the same time like I
like to give
you know both what's going on now and
make sure that that's clear but then
also start reaching back to like how did
things get to be the way they are now
and in that story the sun has already
done something
problematic and
so
the foregrounded story is already on the
table which I I almost always work that
way like I rarely give a bunch of
background
before I've indicated what the
foregrounded story is
I just myself am much more compelled by
a dramatized scene than I am from
background information although
background information can be critical
and and and and wonderful to write
um
but
yeah I I usually have a problem underway
I mean you have that old Greek term in
madius race like in the middle of things
and that the Greeks sort of thought it
was a good idea when telling a story to
rather than go back to the very
beginning of something to just pick it
up in the middle of things and that's
how it's done in that story and that's
how it's done I would say that's
generally how I work
are parts of the background seeping into
the foreground story like you know you
know you never wanted my picture up the
way you know you did with you know
brother Bobby I really don't say it that
way but yeah yeah is it seeping in
little Clues are coming in I I that's my
favorite my favorite way to write a
story in general I mean I'm not like
saying it's the best way but it there
there are many many ways to tell a good
story I mean in an infinite number but
like if you can sort of weave in
the back story like you know maybe give
a paragraph here or like a few lines of
dialogue that happened earlier there
and not sort of like pause the entire
foregrounded story and say okay reader
now we're going to take a lengthy break
to talk about like what happened earlier
in your childhood I I liked if possible
I like to try to bring that backstory in
to the
telling of the main story and often you
know that can happen with dialogue where
people refer to what happened in the
past and that's a way of preventing
having to just take a big break and go
back like if you have a character say
you know well but you did X
and that brings the past in
without having to
stop the action to deal with the past if
that makes sense I just wanted to add to
something I said earlier I was saying
that I often
um like to sort of weave in things that
have happened in the past into What's
Happening Now rather than sort of taking
a big break going into the past and then
returning to the present but having said
that that is something that I I often
like to do I don't always work that way
I was thinking of something
that I had written in which during the
first page or two it was a first person
narrator and he said he referred to a
woman as the only woman he had ever
loved and when I first wrote that I
thought well it might be interesting to
never sort of specify her or never show
you know how he knew her or maybe just
sort of keep it as this
um sort of this figure who
he can't even bear to remember because
it pains him so much so instead of
dealing with that pain he just sort of
thinks of her in these terms you know
the only woman I've ever loved but as is
often the case
with me and I think with other writers
too
like if you put something into a story
you have to deal with it like to to put
something in there like that and then
just to leave it as a as a you know
unspecified you know component of the
story
I don't think a reader is going to
accept that and I if I were the reader I
don't know that I would accept that so I
ended up figuring out who the woman was
that he had loved and I ended up writing
25 or 30 this was a longer piece 25 or
30 pages about the time that they spend
together so
I'm just saying that there are many many
ways to write a story and you find
structurally the way that you think will
serve the best interest of the story
and one other thing I also wanted to add
is something that I got from a Deborah
Eisenberg uh interview
um in which she said something very
interesting you know when you
when you sit down to fix to write
fiction you might think that you want to
write about X
but in the process of actually writing
fiction the things that you really want
to write about sort of come to the
surface and they can almost be
embarrassing because
you have this idea that oh yeah I'm
going to write a story about X and like
you think that it's sort of this
controlled idea that you know
and this happens to people who write
with sort of external plus and so they
just they write about that because
that's what they plan to write about and
what she was saying is like if you're
sort of receptive to what what you
actually want to be writing about
it might be quite different than what
you think or plan to write about and
that that has been a helpful observation
to me